[Music]
[Applause]
with a lot going on in the world of
sports sometimes you miss these stories
following the nba finals you know
there's other things going on and then
all of a sudden you see this uh oh phil
knight is bidding on the portland
trailblazers
wait a minute
really are they for sale and then you
hear well they're not for sale and then
i wonder if the trust of paul allen you
got to liquidate does that mean the
seattle seahawks are for sale and i
thought there's one person that we need
to call he's uh john canzano he's a
columnist and a radio host and he joins
us back on the program uh john all right
help me understand
if there are they are the blazers for
sale
100 they're for sale uh there's no
wiggle room
the paul g allen trust uh dictates that
the trailblazers the seahawks as you
mentioned everything inside that trust
has to be liquidated and it's supposed
to be liquidated for the benefit of the
trust and that trust is supposed to fund
paul allen's passion projects
now we already saw there was a huge
piece of real estate in southern
california that greta garbo once upon a
time nicknamed that sold for uh 65
million dollars in in january uh paul
allen's super yacht the octopus had a
submarine on it and all kinds of cool
stuff it it sold in november uh they
sold that for 400 million so this is
just part of the procedure i think you
know people in this region know the
blazers are for sale the blazers can say
they're not for sale but we know how
that works
um
why phil knight
like and it feels like there's nobody
he's 84 years of age
uh but
why
yeah that's that's the question right
because for years we always thought that
you know he he doesn't need an nba team
he doesn't need an nfl team he doesn't
need a major league baseball team
through nike he he owns them all right i
mean he's got his hands in everything
but if you really look at what phil and
penny knight have done over the last
decade or two especially in the state of
oregon they they have invested in the
university of oregon they've invested in
the uh the health and science and
research facility here they have given
money to stanford as we know but you
know people don't talk about some of the
behind the scenes stuff that i think
makes this make sense
uh when pat casey the legendary baseball
coach at oregon state was being wooed by
notre dame
phil knight who you know reached over to
his rival university and said how can i
help you he personally wrote a check to
help oregon state his rival keep pat
casey phil knight grew up in portland he
grew up in this state he made his
fortune he built his company here i
think this is a hundred percent legacy
play by phil knight doesn't want an
outsider to come in and own
portland's nba team and perhaps move
them
but is he looking at getting the
seahawks and the blazers at the same
time
it's a great question i don't think the
seahawks fit that because i think people
in the state of oregon view seattle is
over there but i wouldn't be surprised
if as you look at the involvement of
alan smilinski with the dodgers and you
know it feels like this they could be a
player in that conversation as well but
i don't think phil knight at 84 needed
an nba team or an nfl team i think this
is all about his legacy dan but that
means the seahawks are up for sale
and have there been like what's the
value of the seahawks yeah i i think
they're looking at the the blazers brain
trust which is really vulcan inc it's
located in seattle they own they uh you
know owned and operated the blazers for
a long time under the paul allen
umbrella um you know i'm told they were
looking at the denver broncos sale uh
allen and company no relation to paul or
jody allen uh they're running that
auction of the pat bolin trust to sell
the broncos that those bids started
coming in at 4 billion and now 5 billion
so i think the seahawks are in that 5
billion plus range and i think you know
eventually the seahawks will be sold i'm
told that they will be the last piece of
the estate to go out the door
and that jody allen has a much deeper
connection with the seahawks than she
does the blazers she may be angling to
come in as a minority owner or part of
an ownership group she i don't think is
interested in owning the whole franchise
but i won't be surprised to see jody
allen involved somehow with the seahawks
when they are sold and they will be sold
closer to a championship the blazers of
the seahawks
i think the question i've been asking is
closer to a championship university of
oregon or the blazers is phil knight
trying to get his championship with the
trailblazers and not the university of
oregon
i think you know in the the nba is tough
we all know small markets huge
disadvantage right and that's why i
think always having the deep pockets of
paul allen was a benefit to the blazers
if you get phil knight in the door and i
can tell you dan people here are over
the moon at this possibility because
they were thinking about outside
ownership group people who wouldn't
spend i think if you get phil knight and
smolinski uh owning this team adam
silver has to love it the other owners
have to love it and the fans here would
love it because i do think it gives
portland a punching you know punchers
chance in the nba
great to talk to you again as always
john thanks for joining us take care
that's john canzano columnist uh
he's been a long time contributor to
this show also uh host of a radio show
that airs statewide in oregon